Tôi chỉ được một lúc thì họ tôi vào mạo tôi.
Dạy tôi, và tôi có sĩ thêm,
hả phải lần nữa và tôi có rừng mạng.
Sau đó, lúc đó thì tôi có ra thì tôi thấy mẹ,
thẳng yếu dành và tâm nằm đến mấy lầm,
bây giờ sau khi tôi có thấy mẹ không thả nữa và tôi có gọi phá ơi và con chế tôi.
Tụi mạng thành phố Hạnh phúc đã quyết định khởi tố hai đối tượng,
mỗi minh hiệp và mạng thiết tâm về tội dết người trong vụ mạng mẹ gái bún tội ở phần phú sĩnh giảnh đến từ vòng.
Theo điều tra, mỗi minh hiệp 202 tuổi chủ ở tình ninh mình,
và tàn thiết tâm 202 tuổi chủ ở tình tuyn quan,
xin sống trong phòng trọng, mỗi được hơn 20 năm.
Nạn nhân là con ziếu của tâm,
nếu tiếp cho một tháng này,
hai đổi tượng đã nhiều lần cùng đánh đặc trở mẹ.
Trong bà ngày liên tiếp thì trò mẹ đã định mỏ lỗi.
Châu ngày ba tháng năm thì bẹ đứng lấy bánh kèo.
Thì châu là, châu Ánh vụ nên tâm đạn đánh châu,
khi phụ mắng trời và mạng hành châu.
Vụ lúc sau thì châu không vào khóc dễ dù ở nưỡa thị cả hai,
mỗi đưa lạnh nhân đến bệnh viện,
nhưng châu đã không qua khỏi.
Bánh, cầm, giói, cầm, giói, cầm, giếp, đánh.
Châu biến, và...
Nếu mặc, châu biến, nướng đưa ra,
in fact, nước kỳ lạ, nhé, hậm, đánh đặc.
Châu biến là mùa và tôi,
để là hãy chân kẹp,
kẹp ở tài và hoài bây giờ sau lấy cái vòa,
tôi có tìm về vụ trước kẹp là mào lâu đưa ra,
và tôi có xì tâm mặt mũi mông,
của đưa ra và có kẹp.
Tôi xì đâm lúc thì,
và tôi vào mào tôi,
giải trời,
và tôi có xì tâm, hả vời lần nữa và tôi có...
Rồi mà,